hi everybody my name is Becca Krauss I'm
happy to be here um I work at GSK in our
statistics and data science Innovation
Hub where my team works on tools and
solutions to support our users across
our biostatistics department and today
I'll be talking about one of these tools
that we created called the slushy r
package which helps our teams build a
bridge to the Future so um we're no
longer at our studio conf anymore we're
we're at posit comp so now more than
ever we have a a wide variety of folks
in in the rooms with um all sorts of
different preferences when it comes to
software and different experiences but
if there's something we can we all know
and we all can agree on here it's that
penguins are really cute and they're not
just adorable little creatures but
they're really really sophisticated um
because they live in these very very
cold windy conditions right and so um
their sophistication comes from the fact
that they work together to stay warm and
so they do this technique called uh
penguin huddle where they group in
really really close together um and it
helps them generate heat and uh conserve
energy and they don't just stand still
they kind of move around in this
coordinated fashion uh so that everyone
has the opportunity to stay nice and
cozy in there so uh like these penguins
um depend on having a nice cozy uh warm
huddle that they can uh rely on those of
us using open source software depend on
having safe places to do our work right
so um in regulated Industries this
particularly Rings true um so I come
from Pharma that's one of uh several
regulated Industries and we put a lot of
care and attention into um making sure
we have stability and consistency when
it comes to the software that we're
using so um like I said a lot of care
and attention is put into making sure
this happens a common solution for um
ensuring this is by creating a lockdown
centralized environment where people can
come and do their work these types of
environments are sometimes nicknamed uh
Frozen environment because they are they
do not change they cannot change a user
cannot modify them and they are snapshot
to a single point in
time the contents of these environments
in terms of the the r packages that get
installed are carefully vetted and
assessed and tested to make sure that
they are you know as accurate reliable
um stable as
possible um if any of you intended the
previous session there was a Pharma
track in this room um just a little bit
ago my colleague uh Ben Aron CIA talked
about how we're growing the use of r at
GSK um we have a lot of new teams uh
teams that are new to R and these
environments have this added benefit of
being incredibly user friendly they can
start learning R without needing to you
know learn how about installing packages
and managing versions and all sorts of
things it's just available for them they
can log in and hit the ground running
now with the increased use of R um we
start to see uh a wider variety of use
cases different teams have different
timelines they have different needs um
on top of that we have people that are
really excited to use new features and
the thing about the Frozen environment
it is it doesn't change right the the
rest of the open- source world uh moves
along very very quickly and so these
environments get out of date quickly um
so how do we support or you know it
starts to to look a little bit like um
you know when we're trying to support
teams and figure out things for them it
starts to feel a little bit like my
toddler and this toy here jamming it in
um so how do we support our teams that
uh where the the provided Solution
that's one size fits all is not quite
the right fit for them you know what do
we tell them to
do well we have another solution that is
accessible to all of us which is the
open R world right where you you install
R and you can use whatever packages you
like um so if if teams op for this
solution they can explore wherever they
want uh they can make changes and access
new things and and they make the
rules but within reason right because
these teams are still working on a
collaborative project where there's more
than one person and and they're coming
up against deadlines a lot of the
times um so they generally need to to
try to stay in the same
area so luckily for us we have uh an
incredible tool at our fingertips uh
developed by posit which is the RMR
package so RM is a uh great a great way
for people to um begin to huddle up and
and get in the same area in terms of
what types of um software they're using
so that they can begin to have something
that's more
reproducible our teams uh they they need
a a little bit more um guidance when it
comes to you know where are they forming
their huddle what are they forming their
huddle around how closely together do
they need to be um what if they need to
to uh go off and get food and and come
back later like these penguins do um so
this is why we created slushy
um slushie is an r package that is
designed to support our teams that want
to use an open our environment um and
need to figure out how to how to huddle
up effectively and
efficiently um our slushy we originally
created it internally and we decided to
open source the code um to share it with
the community and uh so I'll I'll share
the the GitHub Link at the end um but
slushie makes use of a couple couple of
really awesome existing tools um I
mentioned RM already um and it it also
makes use of another tool developed by
package or by posit which is posit
package
manager on top of these uh these two
things it gets us or these two things
alone get our teams a long way uh but
they they still need some additional
supports and so um in addition to these
two things we have some
um we're gu we're adding some additional
functionality to help guide our users
through their Journey so it's nice and
smooth um we're also putting in some
guard rails for them so they can stay on
track better and make sure everything's
nice and easy for them um as they're
adapting to this everchanging open
source landscape
right so we had a few goals when it came
to building slushie and one of those was
to uh help people find a home uh where
they could begin to feel uh warm and
cozy and uh have the confidence to to
hit their ground running with with
building their or uh doing their coding
just just like they do in a frozen
environment so first and foremost um the
RM package is help is um is absolutely
uh fundamental in helping our users
begin to form that huddle begin to form
that home base if you're not super
familiar with
RM what it does is well it does a lot of
awesome things but one of its key
features is helping everyone on the same
team use the same packages and not just
the same packages but the same versions
of those packages so that code that I
write will work for you and vice
versa now that we have a a way to begin
to huddle up we need to help our teams
figure out what to huddle around uh
they're looking to us to to give them
guidance about you know what packages do
I use um so if we think back to our
Frozen environments those centralized
environments and all of that vetting
that happens to to decide what packages
go in there um that vetting results in
in a a subset of packages that are
deemed to be accurate and reliable
um if that decision is has been made at
an organizational level or a department
level we can leverage that and and get
those packages into those um into to be
used by that team and and that is
they're agreed upon set of packages they
can also do that leg work themselves in
either case a vetting step will lead to
this subset of packages that the team
aligns on and it will help to kick off
that
huddle also through that vetting process
process we can be sure that each one of
these packages is going to work well
individually uh but with all the moving
Parts in open source we want to also be
sure that all these packages will be
compatible with one
another in our case um most of our
packages are coming from crayon so when
a package gets released to crayon all of
its checks and and tests get run
automatically and because everything on
cray is so so interconnected there's
also um as a byproduct any other package
that's connected into that package some
way is is checked for consistency and
compatibility so for you know everything
that's uh up to date on crayon as of
today is compatible
together posit package manager is a way
for us to access different points in
time through what's called um snapshots
these cray snapshots are dated as you
can see from the calendar and we can
hook into any one of these snapshots and
get access to the cran ecosystem and
have confidence that everything is going
to work well
together um something else I want to
point out here is with with a lot of our
our newer our users this is a big boost
um in their Learning Journey because
thinking about all the individual
packages and their different versions is
a little bit overwhelming right and so
when we shift to this snapshot mindset
it really simplifies things for them and
all they have to think about is a date
and communicating together is a lot
easier um around
that so with these pieces we have a way
to huddle up we know what we're huddling
around and we can uh be sure that um or
our teams can be sure that everything
they're using is going to work well um
together and individually and we can get
that uh so through slushy we have um
function ity to just get that huddle
into place for the team through the
slushy andit function which uh calls our
mvet under the
hood now we're still our teams are still
um working in uh the open our
environment as part of this Paradigm
right so we're not blocking access to
things they still have access to really
anything they want out there um and it
can be easy and tempting for people to
try new things and and um and ve off
course a little bit uh these teams using
slushie really want to keep everyone
nice and tight together and not not V
off course right we've agreed upon a set
of packages we want to stick to
those so it was important for us to um
as part of slushy to get some
functionality in place to make sure that
we are constantly monitoring um what the
teams are using and so RM does a great
job with this as well and we're just
kind of augmenting it to make sure that
people are sticking to the packages they
they intended to use um as well as the
snapshot that they intended to use so um
it really makes sure that no one is lost
along the
way but sometimes uh teams need to move
around a little bit um you know after
all huddles are dynamic they are
responsive to changes in the
environment and um projects can be long
and and people can change their minds
about
things so uh one example of of of
somewhere people might want to change
things a little bit is through the
agreed upon set of
packages so um let's say a team a couple
months down the line finds a really
great package they've vetted it they
feel really good about using it um
through slushie we've given them the
ability to make sure that that package
can get added in to their environment um
through this this function here slushy
add and it by adding it in officially it
make sure that that FL that package is
okay to use it's no longer going to get
flagged by that previous monitoring step
um and they're able to to expand things
a little
bit another place people might want to
move is through time um they commonly do
they've started at a snapshot and you
know month later two months later things
are moving ahead they want access to new
features understandably um so we want to
give them the ability or we've given
them the ability to to to um shift
things up ahead in some cases they might
um need to also go backwards if
something gets deprecated or maybe it's
a little too risky to make that leap and
they want to go back um either either
way we've we've made it just as easy to
go forward as it is back through the
slushy update function um people can
optionally pass a date so um you know
getting from snapshot to snapshot very
specific Al you would pass a date to
this function otherwise it's just going
to bring everything up to date this
function also makes sure that everything
in that library is going to the new
snapshot and no dependencies get left
behind or anything like that or left
ahead if they're going
backwards
um
so we making the elap from snapshot to
snapshot can be a little bit
intimidating sometimes it's risky people
might be on really tight timeline so um
we want to give them a peak ahead here
so what we did with slushie is is add in
this preview function that they can call
before they actually update all their
packages or revert all their packages um
so this feature allows them to get up a
peak ahead at what is going to change
should they make that leap and they can
um they can make plans accordingly they
can begin to to do their research and
anticipate how their code might be
impacted by this change
and this really helps us helps us
support them through um you know you as
they move around and make that process
smoother so it's a lot of different
pieces um and we think back to our
huddles Penguins don't read a manual on
how to huddle they just know how to do
it from the time they're little babies
and we want the same experience for our
users we want them to have success and
feel like it's easy to get there and
feel like they can just focus on their
their jobs get their programming done um
enjoy the the R Pro the process of
learning
R so one way to to simplify things for
them is of course by creating an r
package and we try to be really
intentional about um you know what is
the minimum number of steps that our
team needs to make and try to really
simplify the functionality uh to reduce
the burden on them so they don't have to
think too much about all this stuff
another way we try to simplify things is
through our training and recommendations
about how to use slushie um so for
instance instead of allowing or or
recommending everyone on the team can
can adjust the environment we we assign
that to one or two individuals who are
responsible for um initializing and
maintaining the environment and everyone
else just follows suit and they don't
have to think too much they just have
their library in place and they can
start using
it um this this decreases the amount of
um you know the learning curve of course
and the burden on the teams but it also
is going to uh decrease the risk that
that environment might change in some
way um by by somebody who's just trying
something
out another way we've tried to simplif
is by creating a config file that kind
of wraps up all of our settings um and
and slushy will read that
automatically so what this allows by
putting a bunch of settings in a config
file an organization or a team can make
a standard config file that they can
apply to all of their
projects so this you know taking all of
these settings out of slushie the teams
don't need to be concerned about about
it we've done that for them um and and
through this config file people can um
or we can customize things like the
package manager URL um whether or not
they should be using a cash whether
there's a cash available um that really
makes it faster for for the teams to get
all of their packages in place um since
everyone is installing the same things
one after
another um they can do all sorts of RM
customizations in terms of um those
settings uh special code that should be
run before and after slushy is
initialized um at the start of each
session and perhaps most importantly is
the list of approved packages that
should be used from Project to project
or the P the list of agreed upon
packages so again teams don't need to
ask that question of what packages
should I use we can just kind of get
that information to them or they can
make that that um source of Truth
themselves and um have that
standardized so all of this um slushy
package has really uh been great to give
uh a predefined kind of off-the-shelf
huddle for our teams to take and use and
make their own um which again is really
excellent especially for for our um for
our newer teams and um another place
slushy has been a big support is for our
teams who are looking way out into the
future for their their
deadlines um so again back to the Frozen
environments they're a lot they take a
lot of effort and um time and resource
to to create because of all the Care
that's put into them so the Cadence at
which they're released is is spread out
a little
bit so a team that's looking way out
into the future um has the opportunity
to to use a future Frozen environment
when it's available instead of kind of
settling for something older right
now and this will allow them to have
some access to to the newer
features so what they can do in the
meantime is set up slushie work with the
team using or creating the Frozen
environment to understand you know what
packages are expected to be in there get
those into place for themselves and uh
update along the
way
and and they can fix on the the snapshot
uh and it's kind of smooth sailing to
the end this is not just great for our
study teams who are empowered uh to to
do this on their own it's great for our
Tech teams who uh can focus on the task
at hand and both teams can move along in
parallel towards a common
future so with that slushie has allowed
us to uh build spaces where our users
can Thrive just like these penguins in
their huddle if you want to learn about
fleshy I'm happy to talk at the break or
you can visit our our GitHub site so
thank
[Applause]
you